you know what online dating is like it's
like it's just like being at a thrift
store
you know what i like to buy first of all
socks
go ahead
uh that looks like we're talking about
hi
hi everyone this is a podcast that's
also a
vlog cast or whatever they whatever a
video podcast
and a guy sent in the a video
of himself making
a how neal feel logo on his wall
and with like tape i don't know what he
did it was and his name is hot tea
hot tea hot tea very good
there's an old norm mcdonald joke
where he it was like the maybe the
funniest joke of the 90s
what where he just did he just talked
about star
search oh yeah and he would do
uh ed mcmahon introducing the accent he
goes please welcome
hot property and it was hot property was
the name of the
band or whatever the [ __ ] it was the
dance squad
uh hot tea um is uh
made the art and is there any indication
of how we did it
paint tape uh
magnetic paint now this does raise the
question
of when i'm at an art museum when
anyone's at an art museum
the little card right how much the
little card are we
reading do you know what i mean like
measurements and then measurements it's
on it's all on
egg it's all on it's canvas is obvious
there's another one
acrylic was always like all right i
don't know what that means oil
oil fine acrylic i get a little and it's
like
cray paper when it says watercolor i'm
like watercolor like what are we doing
what are we kindergarten no watercolor
it's like
don't this shouldn't be in a museum you
truly do not belong in a museum if
you're watercolor
uh you belong on a refrigerator imagine
if you saw their process and it was
like yeah it was exactly a tiny easel
and a tiny
kindergarten chair um
bianca we're filming we're taping this a
little prematurely
yes and you wanna know why how
yeah why it's my birthday on monday
okay what does that have to do with our
podcasts we film on monday and i'll be
out of town
okay where are you gonna be um
not that far out of town but out of town
enough to not be able to come back
got it um you'll be in santa monica
where where whereas we're in venice so i
guess you were right to move this up
three days no uh
anyways this begs the question do
white people uh
make a big enough deal about their
birthday why does it
would listen to me hold on don't jump
down my throat
yet okay there
the joke is well first of all as an old
person
it just you just used to it used to be
your birthday right and then there was
ago you'd say at night oh today was my
birthday right right
then it became now it's a festival
now it's my birthday week and there are
people that say birthday month
even birthday month is wild right
so that's how you feel about birthday
month that's how i feel about birthday
week
this isn't birthday week no no i
understand but you understand that
people make it like well it's my
birthday week
and it's never white men i'll say that
say
everything anything bad about white men
you want we don't go on and on about our
birthdays 100
and i think it's a man thing though men
don't make a huge deal about their
birthdays
what's the difference do you think um
that was attempted murder on neil no
look i know how long that was last sorry
i knew that was fine
neil's counting his birthdays he almost
lost one uh um
okay so here's the thing women like
to celebrate everything
more than men why go on
do some math do some behavioral math for
me
okay can you tell that i feel like
you're walking into a trap that i've
laid somehow
and now as a uh bypoc lady you have to
i just think why can't we just admit
women make a bigger deal out of things
look no no there's not a trap no no no
one loves admitting women make a bigger
deal out of things than me
but a lot of women don't will i get some
blow back
with my female stereotypes you do
because yours are
yours can be wild well they're not
always positive
no and they're they're some are strange
well that's fine but
yours begs the question begs another
question
of a lot of your stereotypes you wonder
what happened to neil
oh i'll tell you what happened
but this one i think it's totally fine
to say women make
a way bigger deal out of things
especially positive things
guys are sometimes like yeah it's i
don't
i don't even think i i don't know why i
think it well i think it's
considered girly to be like it's my it's
my birthday
week like so um
you know what's funny whitney said this
thing on stage i'm all i think it's so
brilliant she said that
uh guys don't guys get guys get
circumcised and they don't use it
nearly enough like imagine if a woman
yeah that's funny imagine if women were
circumcised at birth
well imagine if women had to shave their
faces every day we shave our legs
and our others again not your face
if women had shaved their faces and
necks all day every day
it wouldn't it would be brought up
pretty often that's all i'm going to say
what do you think you've seen women
shave their legs it's like
like there's no it's not meticulous at
all the
vagina i can't speak to him right um
i'm sure it's a little more mature do
you shave your bowl i don't this is not
okay
i don't when neil draws the line it's my
face i mean
no i mean i don't like look there's
trimming
and there's pruning i like to keep a
little taste full of mine you know what
i mean
foliage you know what i mean um so yes
that's what i'm gonna do
this week and i would have i would have
invited you i would have invited you to
my
monday celebration but you don't like
doing party stuff i don't
i invited you to my birthday once and
the guy never again
i'll wait in line for one thing vaccine
no two things
ice cream ice cream no we'll not wait in
line in fact you live near a long-lined
ice cream place but what i did was
bianca
at one point i tipped them a hundred
dollars
and after that point i come in the side
door
i'm a [ __ ] uber eats driver
grab a pint give them they all remember
you
yeah do you tip 100 every time no that
would be wild
i think they're hoping i think they
thought i would uh they're waiting
i mean whatever i was how much is a 100
tip how many
how that would be about nine pints that
would be about eight pints
okay i'm they did good
good they were also giving me so it was
so but i
i figured out a way not to wait in line
there and that
way is money why aren't you saying
online
it's a good point cause you're from the
east coast i know i i
somebody brought that up this week
really yeah so there was a meme or
something
um there was a meme or something or a
podcast by the way i have no idea
and i don't think i've discussed this
with you i may have i have no idea what
i've said on this podcast
other podcasts what i've heard what i've
said on stage
what i've said on the phone right what
i've thought what i've written
what you've heard from someone else no
idea what anything is anymore
because we're we're over contenting
um as people as uh people
were peop the comedian comedy community
of la
has been we're strip mining someone
someone remember that email they're like
10 to 20 posts a day
too much comedians i'm not even getting
into that is that an over exaggeration
or do some comedians post so much i
remember dalia saying he liked to post
i'd go like why do you post photos and
he's like any
uh activity is good interesting so i
don't
know
[Music]
how was your what how was your past week
my past week
um it's cool that jigsaw sent a song in
congratulations thank you jigsaw shout
out to chris rock go see
spiral now who knows where it is
spiral yeah that's what it's called
it's called spiral oh starring chris
rock and sam jackson yay
so and who the sweating
sweating chris rock sweating upset chris
rock uh
that's what chris looked like on iowa
thumbnail anyhow
if you want to know what chris look like
have ayahuasca look at the
still frame of spiral that is so rude
that wasn't not when we did it with him
no i know when i did it with him
it was wild and i it's up to him to
speak about it
but it was wonderful um
uh i've just oh you know what i did do i
finished
a i refinished an antique dresser
uh that feels like a mask
glove situation highly masked
gloved goggles on the roof how do you do
that in an apartment
no no no i did it before i did it
in like uh i have a secret spot mm-hmm
and when i need to do right behind you
behind your ear around your neck go
ahead
you guys remember when i referred to my
woods
class i don't know what they call it
wood shop so
i there's a secret spot if i need a sand
furniture
so i have a so i sanded i sanded it and
then you have to
take off the the paint which is
impossible so it's like
you have to strip it and put all this
goop and then it bubbles
and then you have to scrub it and then
you have to wash it and then you have to
let it dry
pre-stain sand dry
yep it was really annoying but it's fine
i know how to do it so
and do you like it i did a fantastic job
do you that's the
do you enjoy a thing if you made it
yourself
more not like a food or something but if
there's a table
or a chair or do you kind of get even if
it's not comfortable you're like
yeah but i think you enjoy it when it's
good
but when it's bad it's just uh just
showing you your failure right it's like
how long does self-esteem last uh well
with the dresser i can be like anytime
someone called me like you know
i actually you know it's funny funny
story
uh have you ever left
a table or chair that you made
in front of an orphanage for because you
no longer wanted it
have you put it in a dumpster behind a
mcdonald's like a
unwanted child where you're like i can't
i can't have you around
funny enough where my parents would do
the custody drop-off pickup was behind
a mcdonald's wow
what having a bianca we're all looking
what's your rosebud
bianca's rosebud was behind a mcdonald's
in wherever the [ __ ] you're from san
jose
now today and uh whatever it's all
a different form of opening it's never
been oakland that was your
bigotry and then and then uh
and then where apple's from curputino
well that's a division
yes of course so anyhow
it was behind the dumpster parents
playing hot potato
hot daughter with bianca
i don't want her you take her neil
that's me
that's what i heard that's a neal
interpretation of that
okay what'd you do i
was saying last night i caught two bad
ones two two bad sets
was your week and i mean they were fine
but
no but like what i realized is
i'm a sensitive ecosystem
and i know if i'm going to do well an
hour before i'm even on stage
and i have i still have not 13 or 14
years into stand up
figured out a way to make my energy so i
can kill no matter what happened to me
that day
you have a pretty high batting average
though yeah but it's
you i still can't believe i can't
believe you can still bomb
at this time it's i see it happen all
the time
it's people but i remember sebastian's
fourth fallon he blanked
uh tasha's 11th tonight show with jay
leno
he blanked right and you're like how the
[ __ ] does this still happen
and and the answer is nobody knows
like it's uh seinfeld was one time
talking about stand up on an
interview show and he goes if you don't
say
the joke perfect if you say the the joke
is over
it's over and no one knows why right no
one knows why
and it's a mystery and if you figure it
out you're gonna get 800 million dollars
more or less it's what ellen got it's
what sandler got
letterman lena is like you just get so
much money you can't believe it
um seinfeld etc um so
did something happen for your mood to be
like tilted in a way where it's like i
can't get
i think i was just bed boying all day
writing writing
like a st the stage show that i'm gonna
do and it wasn't
painful i'm just a sensitive
[ __ ] like i
tell me a sensitive [ __ ] like
uh like somebody said
a friend of mine will call him john
mullaney
uh we were talking on the phone and we
were talking about being sensitive and
he said the
difference between what i say i'm fine
with and what i'm
actually fine with is about a mile
it's true the difference of like yeah i
can take what i
say i can take i can technically take
anything
technically right but
i'm very sad
inside and i'm also going
i'm planning my retribution right as
it's happening
and some of these are going on 30 years
yeah no you have a you have a rolodex
yeah some of these beefs are going on 30
years
now do they lose
do they does the utility diminish over
the years
i don't think they were i don't think
they were useful to begin with
i don't know i mean in terms of like
does the that like kind of
rage upset utility that like grabs a
hold of you
i don't know i know that are there old
ones that you're like
whatever old ones are just like
this is again i still don't know
i you've never i can't there's another
thing i can't believe i'm still
i still i'm not getting that much better
in life
like i'm older and i'm like i'm still
most
social interactions i'm like oh
how'd that go you check in with yourself
like that was
yeah i it's the i that's why the
nobody's mad at you song is such a
hit yeah it's because it's from an at i
think a lot of people feel that way
and at pretty much every interaction i'm
like
all right we'll see what happens i
thought my my buddy derek
from in and of itself was mad at me for
i thought i'd hurt his feelings
yesterday for four hours
because i made a joke on a conference
how do you
reason with yourself that you know that
that is
not most likely the right
i used to be well they used to be if
i texted somebody and they didn't text
me back within two hours i'd be like
well we had a heck of a run it's
done that i guess i'll never hear from
again we did our best
and that was 20 years and that's what
can you really ask for
from a person and then slowly but surely
it became like
yeah okay they'll probably maybe they're
mad
but i they'll be all right and now it's
derek's not mad at me but maybe he is
because we spoke and he made a joke
about the joke i made
but that is it's so easy who knows that
is torturous
i know i'm in this machine all day i'm
stuck in this machine all day but that
is
it's exhausting to think people are at
you when most people are
so ambivalent but they're so
self-consumed
most people 95 of the time are only
thinking about themselves yeah
and five to ten percent of the time are
thinking about what they were going to
eat
guys maybe there's some more like sex or
whatever but most people are thinking
about themselves
100 and then their physiological needs
so why do you think
you're somehow like and then neil
because
well because of the times i've gotten
written up
you gotta i'm just like well that's but
it's also
grown up catholic growing up yeah
passive regards to mom
punitive dad yeah uh
uh swift swift justice
switch swift swift justice
um and uh like
no no
uh due process just just
you know you know as christopher
hitchens called catholicism celestial
north korea
so you're just constantly um
you know they're constantly worried
about being yeah
so you don't ever just say at one point
like [ __ ] it if they're mad i don't know
yeah i mean you just get to the point
where you're like i okay
i i i gotta what would be helpful for
the other person to do in a dream
in a perfect world would they be like
nobody i think i mean i know so
in a perfect world would it be like oh
by the way not mad at you
derek making the joke about the joke i
made
was like okay i think we're good right
okay
um and and i hope that's often the case
but i
and then people go what a lot of time
it's like what what did you think
huh so i don't [ __ ] know all i know
is i'm a sensitive baby
it's it's not easy
to be me no sure i make it look easy so
anyway keith's here
keith okay come on he doesn't love all
the wires well
take the hint make it wireless for keith
so i guess we'll i guess we talk about
the news
okay uh from what i can tell um feeling
hurt is that you
yeah that's what i just talked about
okay it's like there's a part two
yeah um all right so
oil oil in general got
popped not your skin oil though no not
my sweet coconut oil that i
that i slather myself in um you can see
it on the video podcast a
real nice shine three different oil
companies
got popped within in the same 24-hour
period
like shell uh got ordered to cut carbon
emissions uh by 45
by 2030 which i love these stats like
we're going to go this right here by now
right there
it's just a way to be like go away from
yeah like we're going to do something
but just
with no um chevron
um
the quote is it may be the most
catechismic day so far for the fossil
fuel industry
um if you want to keep the temperature
low enough the civilization will survive
you have to keep calling oil and gas in
the ground
uh that sounded radical a decade ago and
now it sounds like the law so
shell got popped um exxon got
a bunch of them got like stockholders
there was
activist shareholder there's two
environmentalists now
on the board at i can't really tell
based on the article will
put up but um they got a bunch of them
got popped right
uh exxon and shell are the two big and
chevron
i think what's interesting is
it was like two decades of banging the
drum
that oil companies are bad and then it
feels like
covid weirdly made people
aware of climate change yeah which is
completely right odd because that's not
what it was
right exactly they made a at one point
they said
actually when they that's a whole other
issue which is when they were like this
is
it jumped from an animal to to humans
because farms are too close to cities
and did it
overcrowding and factory farming and all
that stuff and we're going to get more
um viruses like that
i don't know why it happened but
it's one of those things like [ __ ] it
whatever it takes
for you guys to get on board with this
bless especially the like viral uh
graphics that said oh my god fish
returning to this pond
and nature's healing yeah look at
this is uh you know what was that town
in italy
uh but it wasn't even yeah and then it
was all photoshopped
like they were mostly photoshopped but
everyone and it's funny because you s
beforehand you'd see if everyone stopped
driving for one day
we would save enough blank to peel blank
from blank
like yeah it's kind of but whatever got
people involved
whatever doesn't really matter uh
yeah i'm it's like take the win
and i'm glad
that they're doing it i guess
i i i don't know it just is one of those
things of like
cool if getting almost getting a
motorcycle accident makes you stop
cheating on your wife cool i don't care
how you got there
they're by the way they didn't they
didn't volunteer these were all like
courts and shareholders so um but then i
read an article that said there's a we
have a
in the next one of five years in the
next five years
one of the years will be uh the
whole earth will warm
like maybe two degrees celsius or
something
which is what the paris accord it's one
of
the five 1.5 and we have like 30 days or
something i think i read the same order
but it's some
crazy like like we don't buy july 1st
it's like if we don't get lower
membership is going to your
health coverage is going to lapse yeah
it's the we're going to we're going to
get to 1.5 in the next five years
i've this is another thing that i've
been saying the whole time where i
if you look at most of the charts and
they go we think it's like no no it's
gonna happen
every bad climate prediction has come
way sooner
yeah than they thought it would because
how could it not
it's all uh it's like uh
force multipliers or right or um
compounded interest of or it's just like
an exponential justice
um so i mean god bless and oil
rest in power king and what truly
oil rest in power king we're not
coming to get you no we're leaving you
where you are
oil what you wanted you want to be left
alone forever
and oil oil are you listening
don't get up oil don't put your pants on
stay down in the ground and um
and enjoy yourself now i'm reminded do
you remember uh
did i tell you the face of death story
the videos
yeah no but a buddy of mine went to see
faces of death in the theater they were
not in theater
he saw in the theater in his town
that's so insane and it's face of death
was a
explain what phases i've seen them all
where they would
just show [ __ ] up [ __ ] up
like like things you don't generally see
people dying
in in gas chambers not not
jewish people like uh people getting it
like executing people
getting animals yeah just bad [ __ ] you
don't want to watch it it's just
rotten.com for the 70s
uh but a buddy of mine saw it in theater
and
uh somebody was like somebody got
like poisoned or something was stumbling
around and somebody in the theater
yelled out
stay down [ __ ] so oh that's all that's
what that's what i wanted
oil stay down [ __ ] stay down
and ah all right now here's a question
come on with the well let's talk
let's talk covet right come on so now
they're saying
it might have escaped from the lab we
don't know but they're
we're gonna figure it out this is by the
way
once they once the leak level reaches
this
level biden said the intelligence agency
agencies are split right if they're
split on a thing that they were once
completely uh against
it that's what happened basically
the reason why okay so obviously the
people who were working with
coronavirus in the lab they got sick
in wuhan in muhammad yes basically
china has these labs where they are
working with
bat bat stuff um
like and and um bad viruses and [ __ ]
like that
you know you know but you know lab stuff
you know bats and laps
um you want to talk about a panty
dropper i work in a
in a lab working with bat viruses
[ __ ] hot daughter
just make sure your roommate's out of
town because
you're about to sue some heavy [ __ ]
and you're going to ejaculate i'm going
to put it to you like this
um so will that's will's been lied on
the sound effects today because we have
a camera crew here and it's a whole
other issue but
right it's made well pretty and it's
with me
well we don't like the splurp song um
now so so i don't know if that's
validates
does it validate trump calling it the
china virus
i think i've never been not on board
with
getting answers from china i think
everyone should be like yo
dude what the what happened here what
did you
do it's not like we went easy on what
happened in chernobyl like we have to
get to the bottom of it i just
i don't know when a fat annoying bigot
he's like
china right but that doesn't mean he's
absolutely wrong
i i i don't they're going to say it
validates them
which fine um or vindicates him or
whatever you want to say
my question is if it did
if a [ __ ] virus if aids started in a
lab which a lot of people
did uh
that's a problem for the country of
origin that did
that or the or the now
it's also just an hr issue of like i
don't know
i got the [ __ ] in my hair and then and
then i went home
and and i was my daughter's birthday
party
whatever and then it just becomes a i
guess the question then becomes you
needed to isolate those people
post haste um but the the weird thing is
when i got sick in mexico when i had
chronovirus i googled because i was like
i
caught some [ __ ] in the world spoke to
somebody else that
also got into mexico i swear i still
think i got in mexico
but because it i was in ensenada i was
in mexico city and then i was in cinahl
and there's a lot of cruise ships there
so i'm like and you did go on that
that uh bad virus lab tour
and they were on groupon fell over the
railing
into a vat no i'm fine
don't stop don't slow the tour down
uh and so when so this is on like
january
3rd of 2020 and when i was sick
i was like i did not catch this [ __ ] in
america and i'm a little bit of a
hypochondriac so i started
googling literally world
virus outbreaks that's what i googled
and i found a new york times article
that said china concerned 25 000 cases
coronavirus and there was no information
so i was like maybe i have this
coronavirus thing yeah
and all i saw was it was a respiratory
thing which was
not what i was having at the time i felt
like i had the flu
uh but i felt like they were responding
to it i mean that article was
written a few like a week before i
googled it so
i don't know like what do you do they
also didn't know you know what i mean so
what well
what would you want somebody to do new
we knew but they the
the the people at the lab must have been
they were good they were they knew they
were [ __ ] up yeah so
then it's like well then what do they do
yeah aren't there like showers that like
come on guys now i've thought of a
sketch idea just
in the last 40 seconds oh come on maybe
racist
we'll see okay we lee
wonka and the cove factory wheelie
wee lee wonka and the cove [ __ ] oh my
god willy wonka the chocolate factory
it's we lee wonka
and the coed factory um
so what happens to augustus is
i know i don't know any of the beats of
the of the movie enough to oh
the augustus falls in the chocolate
that's what made me think of it
yes yes um so in the wee wonka and i'm
sorry our camera crew couldn't film me
saying that
the thing that is canceled once and for
all
thank you wheely wonka and the code
factory ladies and gentlemen
um me and dave are going to reunite
the your prayers have been answered be a
good willy wonka
dave yeah uh yeah
i totally agree but he's black it's
never gonna happen
come on come on we need we need british
or pseudo or
british adjacent like like uh
johnny depp or or um gene wilder
racial equality and inclusion uh
also dave's not going up a set for 30 30
weeks um so anyhow
so i don't if it it's a problem and it
but it's also one of these things like
then what do you do yeah if it's
absolutely true
what do you do sanctions
they we owe they we
most of our debt is to them well then
it looks like that debt's coming right
up i mean they should oh
yeah i mean they should owe a lot of
countries
and everyone get gets together that's
what it is it's not sanctions
it's reparations it's finally
finally someone's black people you're
getting your reparations
let me finish it's from china
for a virus so are we good
black people black people we're square
we're good now get off my ass as a white
man
now um so
whatever so that's a now here's my
second issue with the covet thing
so you know i've been the big proponent
of the lottery system yes
my thing was start the lottery
in january yeah and have it be a
powerball that you
ta that you do the drawing in
a deadline like have the drawing in june
so
if you everyone's got access now
i sh all of their california announced
that they're gonna there's gonna be 120
million dollars in
uh giveaways prizes and gifts like a bag
of a cereal box
also you get to go to willy wonka's
coven factory
if there but apparently with a
california one
if you've already had your vaccine
you're automatically
already enrolled i am i i
am i thought actually that would be
funny ohio had it i thought it'd be
funny if dave won
like he wins a million dollars and he's
like put it on the pile right
um uh
so yeah automatically i am automatically
yeah okay
everybody who's out there that's what
i've that's my entirety the entirety of
this segment was
because the ohio colorado a lot of them
are
from here on out yeah
um great so i'll see you there okay did
we split
just see what it see what it is if i win
you
will see what it is um anyhow so that's
that's coveted stuff what uh
do you wanna do you have anything to add
to the san jose shooting
well one it's just very sad two
um there was a shooting in san jose at a
train yard
uh yeah at the vt like get just at the
metro station like where they
arrive and leave from so it's not it was
just the train station
it's not a train station it's like where
they um you know when they end
yeah the rail yard where the the where
thomas the train
thompson so um is thomas okay
well no but that kid his name's mikey
he went to mike mikey's the shooter no
no no no
a guy in one of the guys that got shot
one of the guys who died
uh went to my high school not the same
year but all of my older friends were
posting about him
and it was weird to see uh just having a
degree of separation
for a mass shooting yeah and my sister
said that that morning when she got up
to go to work she gets up really early
she saw a like a a fire in the sky
and that was the gunman lit his house on
fire then left for work
was that some like joker [ __ ] i think it
was to burn
evidence i don't know but he just lit
his house on fire went to work
and killed all these people so when my
sister went to work she saw this
fire because we live in the same city as
this like this part of san jose
mm-hmm and santa clara's cupertino
high school my mom lives in santa clara
sweetie you know that i
i just everything is a job
we're just josh um i kept saying that
when me and cat went to joshua tree i
was like
just josh um i'm pretty stupid
i love when you have dad jokes because i
love who what better
what dad because it's not gonna happen
any other way guys
it ain't gonna happen dick the dick way
uh
but yeah so then um
that was it just it's weird i don't know
for some reason it's just
weird that it happened in san jose
why i don't know
is he was he a white guy by the way old
white guy
yeah i was going to say if it was
latinos and gangs it's
par for the good it seems like we don't
even talk about it yeah it doesn't even
make them
they kill the same amount of people yeah
that's just a grand theft auto mission
go to the latino guy low rider car
rail yard um but yeah it just it was
really
um weird and then
matt gates said that the reason
basically saying it's cancel culture
like oh
silicon valley they they don't like
cancel the culture that's
but we have the right to defend
ourselves against cancer like it just he
was just
making really i don't try to tell me
about this before i just
matt gates he's in you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
a 17 year old for money
what is it naughty naughty naughty
favorites goodbye naughty favorite uh
but
yeah it just it's just really weird and
sad and
um i just feel bad these people just
yeah
it's just another it's yeah that we have
too many guns
i heard that it is the 61st mass
shooting
this month in america yeah i
was there 61 in the month i don't
remember that i thought that would be
the year
well there's 70 days in a month
so i don't know i it feels like 61
can't be right uh major mass shooting
that's like three a day uh there were at
least 12 mass shootings
wikipedia ain't gonna do it well uh
total number 64 people were killed i
don't know
i who cares it's not i don't mean it
like who cares [ __ ] you
like i mean like it's in them
whatever number it's the drunk driving
of the of the modern day drunk driving
there used to be more driving deaths mad
started and mothers against drunk
driving and they went down
and now they need to focus
on that i think yeah or something or
i don't know how to stop psychos
i don't know how to stop them and i also
am not i have a whole other theory about
gun
violence which we've talked about a
little bit we may have cut it out but i
don't remember
i don't i it's too much i'm over
contented
um there you go
thank you um
now ap
moving associated press
hired a woman named emily wilder
kind of just to work in the office she
wasn't even a writer she was
office manager she was something
something informational that wasn't
uh you know and
then it came out that she
in college she'd written
[Music]
she it they called her rookie reporter i
don't believe that she was even writing
uh she was a news associate uh they
fired her after two weeks for violating
its social media policy during her brief
tenure
um basically
what happened was it was a tweet
about uh
wider's tweet uh it was about i guess
she's jewish and
she uh referred to
sheldon adelson as a naked mole rat
looking billionaire
um i guess that's the entire
entirety of the tweet i don't [ __ ] it
was something that was considered
uh that that basically republicans
conservatives
then flooded the ap with complaints that
you've got this woman on staff
and and then they just like fired her
like uh she fired and then the ap staff
was like wait why'd you fire this lady
and they were like
well because yeah they were they were
people there were barbarians at the gate
and uh yeah the name michelle nadelson
and naked mole rat which
i think if you do a side by side that's
not that absolutely correct
can we see uh no come on but it's never
gonna happen you're asking that
would be the impossible but if you want
to see what she'll name it
he looks like a naked mole rat he looks
absolutely oh my god
he does she was just being accurate yeah
so
basically they uh
jesus
needless to say it was maybe the
greatest search will's ever done
uh yeah he looks like a naked ball rat
she's absolutely right yeah
they fired her for being hilarious um
and then they real and then
later on they were like we [ __ ] up and
they said it was the right decision
but they they said it was a mistake a
process these people
the woman will just sue them right
that's
now maybe she can't afford a lawyer
maybe she can't sue them
but they have to worry about
like amy cooper the bird watching lady
is suing her
employer for firing her and she might
win
there's like a you know the title ix
thing at
uh on on campus rapes right yeah title
nine under obama
changed it so that if you if you're a
man a young man who gets accused of rape
on campus
you are thrown out of school
for on the accusation over 700
guys have sued the schools and most of
them won because it's
it's not that's not due process but that
is
different than that i think is wrong
because
well no no but on the accusation right
but at the same time
should the woman have to go to school
with the guy she that sexually assaulted
her
i i don't know it's very hard yeah the
math is
i feel like there must be i'm not uh
familiar with it so i'm not going to
make a statement on it but
well they have to because like at asu
there'd be no men on campus
if they threw out every guy every guy
who got accused
it's all it's a women's it's a women's
college basically
yeah it's it's swarthmore uh
so wait but what i'm saying is the
if we if you're a um
restaurant or wherever they work people
will dox your ass they will find where
you work and they will bombard
the work with does this person be the
employer the employer and every
workplace has a code of conduct you know
so
rape is one thing but that's you know on
film i think you can i feel like
the employer has a good case to say not
ap because that feels like a just
you just caved into pressure right she
also did a thing about palestine and
israel and
even though she is israel i don't
[ __ ] it's one of these things where
i don't
there was a new york times podcast this
week where they said
that one of these it was like a girl did
a snapchat
who's a cheerleader she got kicked off
the cheerleading team but it was public
school
it went to the supreme court yeah and
the supreme court was like
we don't [ __ ] know they were they
don't literally
were like we don't know yeah we don't
know how to adjudicate this [ __ ]
so i i don't so why how would i know
right how would i know even though i am
probably smarter than a lot of the
supreme court let's be honest
um and but yet i'm sensitive and i still
bomb
and tosh blank on the tonight show and
shit's wild
um and justice is swift
so i don't [ __ ] know i know they've i
know
that these are incredibly complicated
and not unsolvable mysteries
but i am probably going to do a show
called unsolvable mysteries it's like
unsolved mysteries
but they're unsolvable you're doing a
documentary about it i am doing a
documentary about
this but i don't but there's a whole
there's some budget issues that need to
be
taken care of i think though when you
should in the like
is it okay if a uh company in their code
of conduct
start saying don't if you go viral
that's your business i mean you can fire
somebody for
almost anything except color creed yes
you know
all that stuff but the the it's a
double-edged sword
because or a double bind because
they want journalists with a lot of
twitter followers
so they you need to cultivate a twitter
personality
and then then you get hired because of
your following
but if you [ __ ] up in that realm
it's just it's all it's all too
connected and there's gonna have to be a
decision
about what's what or there should be a
statute of
limitations with tweets
or something or but also because people
will go back
well twitter's not that right but what's
the schedule after six years
i don't i don't know that's the reason
why you yeah or you're like that was
when i was 17 and you're
only 22. it's like well yeah i don't
know
um kevin hart was only 32 when he said
that
he would smack a doll house over his son
his gay son's head
he didn't know any better i mean
speaking of he wasn't he was 28 but
we go to trouble the winner circle since
we're talking about twitter yeah
yeah we should sad sad yeah
this is a triple trouble in the winter
circle
um so this is we got chrissy
with trouble in the winter circle and we
also have dominique wilkins okay he's
not treated and have trouble
what's this dominique will get you
that's actually one of these white
people doing right what is the triple
uh benefit we could include if we wanted
shuffle
um so chrissy
teigen personal friend
and uh uh
legitimately uh great person
as far as i'm concerned um as far as
anyone's she's a great i would
i'd bet money i'd put whatever uh
apparently in this this is a story last
week she apparently
tweeted to courtney staunen to kill
herself
um and well a lot is debatable there's
one tweet
no no it's dm's does she have did she
show the dm's yeah she
she tweeted at her but then she had dm
saying she said she had dm she didn't
show the dms
that's courtney snodden said that she
didn't say
what do you say uh
do you have family one's just a slam
butthole uh effing weird uh
i hate you why do you look like a
fabulous why do you speak like a fabio
book
these are all fair yeah no those are
clean shots um
uh dirt now dirt nap yeah so she wished
death on her
okay um and
you know not i will say
i wrote dumb i'm sure there's i wrote
objectionable tweets whatever
i knew not to i i knew
kill yourself at a roast it's all right
like we would say that was a regular
staple kill yourself
for four years it was like and it made
it to general population people started
saying kill yourself
right um and uh it was before
uh uh what was it
closure account or something it was like
hillary said like
somebody like to close your twitter or
something
i remember yeah um it was kill yourself
so
you know she she said kill yourself it
this is a branding thing
it's it's you get known for chrissy's
[ __ ] funny
i don't say that as i have no i remember
telling schumer she was funny and
schumer kind of looked at me i was like
i'm she's not gonna [ __ ] me she's
married to my friend
he sings songs so i can't be right
um and then you get into
pots and pans you just get into a
different brand
well you're really making up for that
couple horrible searches
those searches were they were atrocious
and then yeah i know i could tell i was
like
yeah because will couldn't find what the
lady tweeted
emily what's her name yeah i know
um so we can we comfort each other uh
so she just got
she i don't want to say she hoisted
herself on her own petard
i think there's a fatality there there's
this is
she's she's petarted she's so [ __ ]
[ __ ]
she's [ __ ] straight up i don't know
what to tell you
this is so funny she's [ __ ] she's
chrissy teigen
is petardi in this case
she's also she's chrissy's [ __ ] great
and all this [ __ ]
the good and badness of all this stuff
is i don't know what she lost there was
like a bloomingdale's thing or some pot
in the pots and pans
her pots and pans aren't going to be
sold whatever she can just go direct to
consumers she's got a zillion followers
uh in a month it will just be
it's this [ __ ] is like a orgy of
cancellation where you're like
did i [ __ ] you or did you [ __ ] me in the
ass or did i eat your wife's [ __ ] like
you don't know
everyone did wait you got canceled you
cancelled somebody
right you somebody said something about
someone and then you the lady said
some asian stop asian hate
wonka and then wee lee wonka and the
coven factory
i'm gonna you know who i'm gonna sell
that too it's tucker carlson you'll see
um he's doing a sketch show yeah i would
watch his schedule it's funny that
tucker carlson i won't even make that
joke
um here's the problem with christy yeah
problem with chris is that she
just she from the outside looking in i
don't know her obviously at all
but as a just an audience member
she like wanted it too much she
liked attention that that attention she
got from
twitter she flirted with it
so much and for a while she was on top
chrissy teigen is
all alone right now she's the queen of
twelve she's
slaying trump you know all that [ __ ] and
i don't think she realizes that oh that
good is the same the same bad is good
always
it was always part of it right what i'll
say
is it's like the kardashians thing or
the connie thing or any of this stuff
people go she wanted it too bad no
she was good at it and she got a
shitload of attention for it
and i don't buy the thing she wanted
attention where the
everyone yeah so does everyone no i
understand that my point is that she
she's that for me her like twitter
situation
is really gross and i'm not saying her
involvement in is gross but she also
gets
really gross tweets towards her you know
she's a child molester
babies like all that stuff to me i don't
know
i would be i'm sensitive i would be out
i wouldn't
i'll say this they had a halloween party
and they didn't
eat babies but they did have one of
those nitro ice cream
stations did you stand there the whole
time i like three three trips i believe
wow
it was pretty wild to the point where
the ice cream people thought i was weird
did you tip 100 i didn't didn't need to
um anyhow yeah like do you know what i
mean like
you know her she has like 20 layers that
i would have
already been out yes whereas she's just
like no [ __ ] [ __ ] you
no now that hurt my feelings you guys
are asking [ __ ] you and
a lot of it's like i get twitter's
unsolicited opinions for sure but
also there's kind of like even though
she's very funny there's a
there's a difference between the move
she makes on twitter than and like
compared to like a
proper comedian like they're even though
comedians say the most wild [ __ ] they're
not
like geez there is a we
get trained in
comedy clubs yes and writer's rooms and
sound stage is where you go that doesn't
work
thank you and i don't know why you know
what's the thing that doesn't work and i
will never know why sketch is about
nelson mandela
people don't like people black men doing
at mandela impressions
there was me and dave tried it yeah it
didn't work
there was a thing on the ass bees what
was that
mandela's boot camp no it's funny
it's very funny in fact did i bring i've
got one of the t-shirts upstairs
yeah and then tracy morgan tried one
at the espy's when seth was hosting i
was like
i'm just letting you know this may not
work i'm just telling you now
i don't know why so there are things you
know
you're more trying to exactly yes so
there's a refined like
you have a better sense of the uh
the target and the target demographic
like you have a better sense of how
it's encoded and decoded whereas
sometimes when it's just like i'm funny
i'm great like everyone in my circle
thinks i'm hilarious i kill at parties
i'm killing on twitter great great great
girl there's some haters there's some
haters like
you're gonna put your foot in a bucket
at some point because
you're not you're almost a little out of
your league even though you're keeping
up
you're still like not you don't have
that like
it's it's like unrefined easy so so you
just get
your you i i
it's also it that was a long time ago
and it was like there kind of was no
rules where it was a bit lawless and
like yeah kill yourself
i think the problem is that from then to
now
she's also claimed like i'm being
bullied and uh this is not cool to say
and people wish that so
it's right i think the corporate yeah
that's the hypocrisy but there's also
the corporate element the hypocrisy
[ __ ]
everyone's guilty of some level right i
love cr i
really care about crazy so what do you
think what do you
talk to chrissy oh she'll never i mean
no i just mean like what do you think
she's petarted what is it
in here's the thing with chrissy though
because
she's managed to stay in headlines with
her tweets
you know what i mean with not even more
than
sometimes more than um john with
his music so
it feels john does a joke of like i'm
chrissy's husband
she's kind of up there in the tila
tequila world of like oh on twitter you
know chrissy teigen like she has
followers she that's like kind of a
thing she's known for
on that platform so i don't to me if i
was chrissy
uh ten five scandals ago i would have
just been like you know i'm good
she quit and then came back that was the
thing she did quit and then yeah
like three weeks even after she when she
quit i looked at her twitter once and i
thought it was discussing her instagram
everyone's saying leaving pizza slices
for pizzagate yeah
would i i would find it personally
unbearable
i don't get why to keep engaging in
something that
it has been is so gross towards me
that's what i don't understand about
because the rewards are sweet
the attention for it being funny and the
positive pants
[Music]
[Music]
i just i feel that like when i looked at
her social media it gave me
massive amounts of anxiety it was just
like they're going
never i'm sure she has
words muted and blocked i mean i'm sure
her version of it is probably far
less toxic but just that it's just that
you're
it's a diabolical it's a very
combustible uh
organism twitter it's very combustible
it's combustible in a way that
famous people have never had to deal
with presidents have never had to deal
with
like dictate like it's a big there's a
reason dictators
shut it down and control it because it's
like no i'm not
no i'm not i don't play all that i don't
play all that
uh well like literally i i mean i had
five
dm's from australians and i had to go
for a walk i'm like
yeah well i think it was i think i would
have i think you deserve probably 25.
but then i saw that i saw a thing about
it then i saw a thing
about a mouse plague in australia
a mouse somebody sent me that too i
didn't look at it and it's
frightening and then i was like i'm not
wrong
but it's it's only a little part yeah oh
yeah
the lady was like the lady was like uh
when mice are going
i can't i don't i so don't care about
australia's animal problem
i'm just saying when the lady was like
when the mice get across my pillow at
night
it's a little unsettling like okay not
wrong guys
that's and she's she was she wrote to
you from the four seasons in melbourne
um this is a what are the white people
doing
what are white people doing well you
[ __ ] previewed that yeah really
connected today
getting a phone call ooh it's australia
i'm like stop talking about our animal
problem anyhow
dominique wilkins you know dom you
remember dominique wilkins absolutely
not
remember michael jordan's yes um
remember the don contes where he jumped
from the free the line and
he it's a big one there's a big he
jumped from the free the line
and he he won michael jordan there was a
guy
did they get a head start he ran from
the other free-throw line and now
it wasn't there there have been better
free throw line dunks etc etc
dominique wilkins was the
he was like a combination michael jordan
and blake kind of
cool in the 80s uh
an explosive basketball player anna
and uh he's he
he played in atlanta he's like the
second most popular
atlanta athlete ever after hank after
hank aaron atlanta
and he got turned down by a restaurant
in atlanta
this week atlanta and um
[Music]
because literally just on some like well
it's a wardrobe issue
well it's uh we'd have tables yeah
yeah and you can't believe it still
happens
you can't i i y even i still ca
i can't believe people would
corporations would go through last year
and not absolutely shut the [ __ ] down
in terms of like we can't do that week
this is the
now then the people tried to the
restaurant trying to
say what did they say they said it was
uh
they had a thing we do our best to
accommodate all our guests however
we have received consistent complaints
from our patrons regarding other guest
wardrobe choices
as a result to protect our restaurants
culture we installed a
minimum standard in our business casual
attire dress code which includes jeans
and sneakers but prohibits baseball caps
and athletic clothing including
sweatpants and tops
uh he wasn't wearing that though i know
and they're the thing he said there were
other there were people at other tables
dressed far worse than him and i have
some you're not gonna believe this
they were white anyhow it was [ __ ] up
and um and he's a good man
and i say this because he follows me on
twitter
no i've always it's one of those that's
one of those things of like life is long
things where like that i used to watch
that guy
he was the one of the he was the [ __ ]
uh
who's the best dunker in the nba it was
blake now it's like
kiwami nope um just there are no like
there aren't like specific there's a guy
whose last name is
uh zach levine is probably the best the
luke guy
no he he's he's actually does not in
good shape
weirdly the luca and there's another guy
who plays for denver
denver named uh joe kitch and they
there are most guys in even for
white guys they're out there you have
bad bodies what does that mean
white guys luca doncic and who's is that
the greek
uh joe kitch look at this [ __ ] [ __ ]
wow he is doughy dough did it and by the
way
lost 15 pounds like this is this is post
this is where it's headed this is where
it started and where it's headed are
both
you know in a in a bakery it's the it's
just formula saving metabolism
yeah now meanwhile he's busting
everyone's ass so
and then luka doncic i love them
a little bit i've sent you two
leukodontics
uh after i watch them i feel like
i'm like i should work for espn two
different
two different look at antics things
where he he dunks over patrick beverly
in game one he yelled too small
he yelled too [ __ ] small and then the
next game he did it again and yelled
too little too little his way
which is so little and patrick beverly
who's like an
[ __ ] and like a fighter oh yeah
doesn't even
he's like pop back at him because it's
like
i don't know okay in this situation
don't you feel
like a little bad i mean his feelings
are probably that of course his feelings
are hurt but
that's kind of different his feelings
are hurt but like
they were the next well first of all the
nba
they're they dumped popcorn on russell
westbrook
they spit on a [ __ ] guy that's
disgusting the guy
who spit on spit on uh trae young from
atlanta
that that's the sec he's in the second
row
he's atlanta behind
50 cent's date went like this because he
spit on her
also and julianne moore
hollywood royalty julianne moore had to
get some dribble
yeah that guy that seat i've had that
seat
okay you know somebody to get that seat
that ain't [ __ ] so what happened to
that guy
that guy's banned for life from the
garden but he's gonna be banned from
everything he should get you hate to say
someone should get curb stomped
just uh but and then there was another
guy
john morant his someone said to his dad
in utah
i should put a i'll put a nickel in your
back and watch you
dance boy on tuesday
[Music]
so neil why are you so surprised then
neil
because they're corporations they i
understand that people are
well i'm surprised by this too i can't
spitting
like dog you'll get [ __ ] murdered for
that
yo dumping popcorn on russell westbrook
i don't i just don't understand
so [ __ ] up maybe these people forgot
how to do it maybe i'll give them the
benefit of i think
something happened during cover where
they were like i don't i don't even know
how to spectate anymore i think uh
athletes
people are weird like the people want to
touch animals at the zoo
blake says it's like being an animal to
zoo it's like you know the people like
tiger you know i think it was in san
francisco and the tiger was like what's
up and he came out of the sanctuary and
killed the kid
yes so i people just love that
it's why people are dicks on the
internet there's just a barrier
partition effect is what the is what
the what i've learned in my prep
for my documentary partition effect the
partition effect
they think i can't believe trey young
didn't he just
went like he winced because they would
get
they'll run our testing yeah um what
happened with that sorry i only know
that
with the runner test what what did the
fan do or was it
through uh threw a drink at him insane
yeah
and then he choked him oh no i mean he's
he went
yeah he went into the and stephen
jackson went in melee
melee i mean melee it's too crazy it we
don't have it we haven't
dedicated it we should do this the next
time you're going away we'll just do a
malice at the palace episode
please because it's unbelievable and
then you just explain these sports
wild sports yeah jermaine o'neill
they're literally pouring beer on him
like we can't we don't okay because i
have five thousand questions already
um focus so yeah i i'm
i'm
the fact that i'm surprised by racism is
not a testament to white people
it's or atta it's it i'm still
trying to believe in people do you know
what i mean i'm still trying to believe
that people are going to learn a little
something
and i'm a cynic so
and i'm still going like you're still
[ __ ] doing this
but but think about it let's just take
away racism
put in anything that you just think i
mean it took ayahuasca for you to change
a lot of your views on things that you
would never change no matter what
you know so i don't know
it just feels like people got it right i
watched it for everybody
i don't know what to say
[Music]
i don't know what else to say come on uh
so yeah i don't even know what we're
talking about but but racism
like i can't believe
yeah the amount it used to be death yes
so
it's it's uh spit it's like spitting
it
it's like no you don't intentionally
spit itself and the guy
went he like lunged and did it like you
thought you
what got in i understand you were
excited and you know it's the playoffs
i've you know what i've been doing
recently with uh
basketball to make it seem really
unimportant is just imagine it's
checkers and then it's like why is
everyone yelling about checkers
which is by the way it's as important as
checkers
but when the uniforms you get right i
don't watch and my
life is yeah you're fine girls get to
like look at architecture and design in
the time that guys are
worrying about sports women get to
cultivate other
interests and hobbies uh benefer
um how do you feel about this neil i
don't
i have a question yep do you think so
she breaks up with a-rod
because of a hilarious situation on one
of the reality shows i watch
so she breaks up with a-rod because
a-rod was
kicking with his girl immediately
goes back to ben or they do that thing
like do you think
just with your exposure to famous people
that's a calculated move
or is that just a because it feels too
on the nose
i don't know i maybe do people actually
make these pr
like yeah but usually one of them is gay
in one of those things like a beard
situation
so if in terms of like side deals right
um also why go back to such a
controversial thing
when you're famous like is it all just
help does is it like what dilia said
like
it's just content yeah it no no p no
press is bad press
i always the thing with that
relationship was to me
it was it made affleck look
affleck didn't get he like kind of
squandered his oscar
prestige with with dumb
space movies and um although there was a
clip of him doing
voice doing the commentary on armageddon
and he's literally like what the [ __ ] is
this
like why he's like [ __ ] on the plot
and it's
very funny
actually worth listening to i don't know
if we i asked michael
why it was easier to train oil drillers
to become astronauts than it was to
train astronauts to become oil drillers
and
he told me to shut shut shut the [ __ ] up
so
that was the end of that talk great yeah
so he's like i have like some [ __ ]
funny dude
uh and it
kind of made him look now it's racist
that he dates a latino woman and he
you know any low rent
you think it makes it with globe run
yeah why
it's jlo she's not because it was
it was the you're talking about the time
at the time yeah it was like strip it
just felt she had dated diddy
it was like it was just more different
he was like in her video smacking her
ass
and it was just kind of like cheesy not
the greatest
so i don't know it was a bad crossover
yeah i hope i hope they are falling in
love
you know what this reminds me of that
clip there's gonna be a generation that
doesn't know how great
not everyone but certain the um the dvd
with the commentary on
you know how many secrets have been
spilled on the commentary dvd
go watch your favorite thing and then go
try to find the commentary one people
weren't
because they were just like okay we have
to watch the movie and talk about it
fine
yeah with like a group of people who
made the movie and then they just forget
they're being recorded
the my favorite one is uh stephen
soderbergh
and scott frank on the limey
i believe they're kind of just arguing
about the movie
and it's and and uh scott says something
seems like well
yeah i don't know if you come to set up
they're just
but they are yeah it's good it's just a
director writer relationship
in public that was very enjoyable
especially for you
oh i did uh i watched it uh
like there was nothing to watch and i
put in a jackass and i put on the
commentary
the secrets are spilling on the
commentary no one is watching jackass
commentary no so if you ever bought it
and me and dave chappelle did one for
dvd i hope that
i hope itself
um i think we re-recorded one also
if i'm not mistaken did you have fun
doing it
yeah it was fun it's a yeah it's just
you and him
no it's me and him and it's a little
there's something performed it's like
there was a crew here earlier
it's us but it's a little winky yeah
it's a little did you feel the
difference
it's like a little bit like now you're
back there's house there's guests here
neil's sat again they're gone do we have
time for anybody
anybody oh this is what i well we will
do
anybody say this story does anybody see
the story
[Music]
that's okay um did you watch the friends
reunion
no i don't like friends oh got it all
right i liked one
like two episodes were very funny to me
yeah
and then you just start realizing like
do i like friends
i'm gonna stop watching i they were just
i like the episode where no one believes
that ben
stiller is an [ __ ] and he only shows
that he's an [ __ ] to
chandler because i think that is a great
allegory for what happens in real life
because the amount of times you're like
that guy's an [ __ ] may not happen
this week
this month this year at some point
everyone's going to realize
the thing i just saw so that episode's
very good
and the one where they get free porn and
they don't want to change the channel
but they're so
like disgusted by it but they can't
they're like that's free i
that's whenever i hear sitcom ideas i'm
like that's funny
i love singing you don't like sitcoms
not gonna watch it but that is did you
ever watch friends
i watched probably three four episodes
maybe this first season second season
i remember a joke where chandler said
i'm or joey's told chandler
i'm gonna wear all your clothes oh yeah
and he started
with [ __ ] 14 layers of shirts and i
was like that's
[ __ ] hilarious that's funny uh story
there's a side note about
ben stiller um
our relationship is vague
and when i see him at say like a nick
game he hugs me
and i'm like
i don't have his number or anything but
it's i can't explain it
it's like he feels like i think i have
to hug neil
and i'm like i'll hug ben maybe he just
thinks very fondly he doesn't that's the
funny no he's not mad at me no no he's
not mad at me or anything why don't you
think he thinks fondly of you
i just think i i can't explain it it's
like uh he has to
i can't i don't feels like it not he's
not mad at it he's like uh it's just
some l.a [ __ ]
performative no it doesn't get anything
from it it's like i don't want to
i don't want to just shake nearly if he
thinks you need it
maybe he sees something in me and
i actually watched 10 15 minutes of it
and
uh i don't like
reunions of any kind family especially
no um i don't like reunions
i don't like i don't like reunion tours
i don't like
remember wins i don't like i just think
it's
corny as [ __ ] and it's exploitive and i
guess it is
fun for the fans but nothing happens
and then watching the show watching it
they all come into the stage one at a
time and knowing about tv i'm like
they've all been there four hours they
just sent them in one at a time
they're all waiting maybe they yeah but
maybe and maybe they didn't see each
other ma
i bet they like had separate holding
areas so they didn't see each other
before they saw each other on camera
which fine uh but i don't know
uh it's it's real it's it's
it's dvd it's not even dvd commentary
it's uh
it's what they used to call an epk an
electronic press kit they probably still
do
they still do and it just felt like an
apk
um which isn't good
it i think it's popular no no but just
that sounds
like oh it's not interesting nothing
happens but it is like
show i don't i i don't know i don't like
i feel bad looking at their faces
already some of them are
some of them are easier to look at than
others um what's funny is there's a
picture of um
paul rudd with lisa kudrow and paul rudd
looks like james corden
anyhow um
so oh this i think is worth talking
about for russia
you know this woman naomi osaka yeah uh
she's the
number i think she's number one ranked
she's also
low-key the highest paid
female athlete of all time she last year
she made more than serena
right she made like 15. she made 39.5 or
something
and so and she's 19 or something
um she's mixed she's black and asian and
uh or as tiger woods called it habit
hypoclination
and um
number two in the world she's number
ranked number two and number one
in money um so
she she said i'm not doing press right
at the french open is there something
worse about the french or the european
uh news
no i what she's saying is
she it's funny watching a young person
like a
the good it's like the upside of gen z
millennials
incredibly entitled make me roll my eyes
half the time
but then she basically said she made an
instagram or said hi everybody hope
you're doing well i'm writing this to
say i'm not gonna do any press during
roland garros
i've often felt that people have no
regard for athletes mental health and
this rings very true
whenever i see a press conference or
partake in one we're often sat there and
asked
questions that we've been asked multiple
times before and ask questions that
bring doubt into our minds and i'm just
not going to subject myself to the
people that doubt me
which is great millennials at their
absolute
gen z at their worst and also
good for you yeah like why why did we
sign up why
did we because the leagues
because it is good for the drama of the
league
but to find them i mean isn't there
something that's why they find them
because it's good for the drama league
to have them
talk about the game gets them on espn it
gets them on the news
bigger swirl sharing photos same
experience probably better for
the bottom well yeah more or less unless
they walk out even that's good
but the the uh
yeah it just [ __ ] made me laugh i'm
like ugh and also
good good like it is weird that
yeah it is weird that we
accepted that as like no you have to
yeah you lost now sit down and let us
humiliate you that's why i love
marshawn yeah that she she actually had
a clip on her
the marshawn ledge i'm just here so i
don't confine my favorite part of i'm
just here so i don't confined
is that he tried to do a slightly
different line read on every
time i'm just here so i won't get fined
i'm just here so i won't get fined
i'm just here so i won't get fined he
did a little something different every
time
and it's what i love about
it's one of the upsides of the internet
is naomi osaka does
drake doesn't need to do an interview
right you're not gonna make him
he has more followers than you if he
wants to release something
he'll put it's like dave doesn't do
interviews because he
people will listen to him more than
they'll listen to the new york times
tim dillon actually the comedian tim
dillon new york times
contacted him about they're doing a
story about rogan
and they contacted tim and he wrote back
with due respect
please [ __ ] off and that's the beauty of
the internet tim dillon's
patreon he makes 150 grand a month
on patreon and it's [ __ ] hilarious
that there are the entire paradigm has
changed
comedy i would talk to santino about it
today comedy didn't change for 30 years
and then it changed uh um
7 percent in five years where
the everything changed and it did being
on a sitcom now is
like punishment yeah that's bad it's
like doing a corporate
like it's like bombing for 50 grand
at a luncheon that's what doing a sitcom
is like you know
like why would tim why what
you can't even explain it to people
well also because before the the
the only way you got your face out there
and you can make your own statement was
like the news came
being the third lead on a funny show
right
santino said the amount of fans he gets
from podcasts versus being on
the most popular sitcom in the history
of fx
dave right is this
the bobby's podcast dwarfs it
right like they don't they're like oh
yeah i guess you're on that too
so what's bobby's dick look like like
they care more about
it's so cool it's so cool right it's
just like a
power shift which is great and so naomi
osaka doesn't need to do press
right and with 40 million dollars she
also can pay your fine yeah what's the
fine
okay she should bring she should bring
it in singles
and like in okay one two
three is this enough yet for not getting
humiliated
how much more money do i need to pay you
to not be embarrassed
okay here you go organization
i'm sorry that i [ __ ] up your thing by
not allowing myself to be humiliated
it's wonderful and you can take that to
the bank charlie
well you you make me prouder every
segment um sometimes you make me less
proud but a lot of segments you make me
more proud
we didn't think we would have enough for
an episode we have too much too much uh
we have a lot of video and audio
questions let's do some emails as well
[Music]
hey neil and bianca here is a little
jingle
i don't have any music i don't know how
to do any of that stuff but
i think it would sound better the
ejaculation song if it was like
this ejaculation is this what it's like
to be a woman
hold on this is what it feels like to be
a woman talking to guys
most of the time just like honestly just
oh yeah
all right go back to the he started
singing it ejaculation
yeah ejaculation
[Music]
i can't even this is so off i'm gonna
throw up
stop it [ __ ] swing in a miss
it's beyond that it's in this in my soul
it's just being a woman is being like
that level
that quality being pitched to you
constantly yeah by the way i think he's
doing that and making fun of that yeah
no he's being funny but but
[ __ ] imagine if when every time you
walked outside this guy walked back down
he said
hey yeah yeah just one of them i don't
have any music or any
yeah i need a jacket that's a guy's
that's how a guy wants an interaction
with a woman to go
hey i don't want to ejaculation
um yeah hit it hi neil
hi binky hi hope you're doing well
and i just wanted to post the or pose a
theory to you guys and see what you
think about it
okay the life is
high school brackets but with more
responsibilities
um but think about stuff like uh
sitcoms right especially the ones that
do relationships right good example
friends since obviously that's been
force fed dollar froze once again
um that's a lot of relationship stuff
and a lot of it
feels very high school we were on a
break
does that not scream high school to you
just gives off that vibe of
this could easily happen in high school
you could if you plopped in
that exactly this exact situation in
high school saying
it wouldn't it wouldn't change um
and as a real world example we could
throw in
diddy or puffy love as he likes to be
called obviously
apparently uh posting a picture of jlo
on his
how old is that dude like 50 odds come
on my guy
you know what i mean so that's very high
school to me i've just
i don't know subposting sub ig posting a
is x girl from 20 years ago
i don't know guys life is high school
theory
how does neil feel what is bianca
well he is attractive i feel like we
have
maybe the highest amount of mixed people
listeners they it you can't find the
stat
no but ever you're always ambiguous yeah
um well if he that's what
you're telling me that's one in
australia i don't know if he is
australian i think he was
i thought he's british but okay maybe
nice house though
you can tell no i know but you can those
are expensive windows
that's an expensive blind those are
expensive lines and those are expensive
windows and i bet he went low angle
because he didn't want to show how rich
he was and if you look in the reflection
of the windows there's more there's a
ghost are you a lady at brunch
trying to find her no this guy's doing
good um
uh yeah it's the martin mull the
comedian
actor said in the 70s hollywood is high
school with bread
no i don't know if he meant money or
actual bread i still don't know
i'm like was bread around then uh uh one
of my favorite
internet writer writers about internet
culture freddie deboer is his name
f-r-e-d-d-i-e he's got a sub-stack
freddie de boer d-e-b-o
okay um wrote a blog called
everything is high school and it's so
[ __ ] good i don't know if i sent it
to you
i sent it to so many people it's so
[ __ ] he wrote it like maybe three
weeks ago
oh wow that's very on the topic uh
it's all this [ __ ] is high school is
what it's called from may 6th
of this year um it's
everything it's basically his theory in
this article and i think he's right
is that we work
backward from i like this person
intrinsically
so therefore i'll support his
opinion about whatever or i just don't
like this person
and i'm gonna go well i don't like him
because of his take on israel
right you don't like him right you don't
like to quote him to quote the article
you don't like his animal spirit you
just don't like him intrinsically and
now you're trying to work backward from
but yes everything's high school the
middle east is high school
every the [ __ ] uh asia's high school
it's just it's high school with bombs
basically right
people are not emotionally mature i'm
sensitive
pretend i'm not exact revenge over
30-year timeline lines uh
yeah the people are not have no
emotional intelligence and it's borne
out
in almost every interaction trump
getting to the front of the line
[ __ ] like that silly but also the
problem
is that everyone no one feels it
so no one feels their hypocrisy you can
you know be rational like okay you know
what
i'm being a dick you know that happens
but most people
aren't telling themselves i'm completely
biased
towards this person i'm biased i'm just
intrinsically biased against i say that
a lot when people are like
what do you think is so-and-so's comment
i'm like i don't like him
or i don't like her just often
off the strength i don't like her or him
so oh yeah so therefore i so t
i literally say so take a discount from
my opinion
because i just don't like that person
like if there's
people that have been rude to me while
i'm working and they're famous and there
are
a handful when they do something i'm
like no that was really funny but like
[ __ ] her because she did that thing to
me
so that i'm mad i'm still mad about that
so i can't
really give her her flowers or whatever
so yeah but how do we because
the it's almost the hypocrisy of
it's we like scream let's just take
republicans and democrats like
you just said you would do this and you
didn't do that or you honor this one or
you don't it's not a big deal when this
guy does it like it's so
it's mine thing is what we just don't
like liberals
so whatever they're doing we're just
guilt which is why
when liberals or democrats just
try to negotiate because there's no
negotiation they don't like
never gonna like it so you can either
get the [ __ ]
shoved through through budget
reconciliation or you can try to
negotiate and water down it'll be worse
and you won't get any credit
from them or you're from either side so
just do it
just i can do it that guy's hot and i
look forward to you getting that view
when you're on your back
and he's maybe ejaculating you get that
what the heck why did this get so
graphic all of a sudden goodbye
you've got man bianca love the show i'm
a 42 year old married lady who is also a
therapist
who just wanted to comment on the
ejaculation sex frequency discussion
from last episode
people often women need to get over the
masturbation stigma
our society has unreasonable shame about
masturbation based on outdated ideas
from religion social mores etc
it's just a biological process data and
experience have shown me that healthy
relationships benefit from a certain
amount of physicality
to maintain connection it's a literal
swapping of spit and fluids that goes a
long way
besides the obvious positives of more
sex the process connects the microbiome
over the pair
and makes all the little irritations
feel less huge
hopes this feels relevant please don't
end season one and make us wait
love you both um yeah i mean
of course she's not of course she
thought i was saying that there's a
master
i don't know if she was saying that
women are
women's masturbation women masturbating
is stigmatized
that's what you say yeah i don't that i
was saying that
men men's masturbation is stigmatized by
their wife
like women will go like ugh i've nev if
a woman's masturbating guys can go
ugh they go hey hey
hey bianca i don't have any any i don't
know any music or anything but
ejaculation um so
i i know what she means that it is
stigmatized
i'm more just saying
sex become other your mates
your partners or girlfriend or
boyfriend's
sexual metabolism somehow needs to be a
reflection of your
glory after in relationships and it's
like it
was pre-existing before you
what are you going to do now it was like
that i
i need to ejaculate once a day what do
you want to do
i it's not disrespectful to you it's not
it's like
this happens to me in relationships a
lot where it's like you're mad at me
for the thing you liked about me
and now are they really you don't want
me to work
even though i the thing you liked about
it was the work
and you you're you somehow think
if i work i work seven days a week
before i met you but now working seven
days a week is somehow disrespectful to
you
even because i should have changed it
when i met you is that the conclusion
you're drawing or is that what they've
actually
said like so much uh yeah i've had that
specific
um conversation and i had it recently
with a guy who
who was in a relationship and was like
said the
almost verbatim thing i just ladies or
gentlemen comics are like surfers
they're gonna do
comedy above anything like surfers are
like they're
wives and labor it's like i'm just good
yeah so
i don't know you have to just be cool
with that yep but
a lot of people think it's a referendum
on them they think it's a reflection on
your feelings for them and it's like
no i did this before i met you i worked
i wrote every day i did this every day
the thing is though neil you
i don't think you you're almost like
you know how when you say white
privilege and why people lose their mind
you're celebrity privilege
like you get a certain type of girl as
well damn right i don't she's brunette
uh no but you get a type of girl
that you know there's an added
insecurity that comes with dating you
with whatever certain type of girl
you're getting because she's like
he's gonna get too popular and then i
don't
you know i don't even know it hasn't
been that honestly it hasn't been a
competition thing but it is
not competition but you it's an insecure
girl
who looks to a high status guy
for four points for like
i'm gonna get some of his refl refracted
if this high status person likes me
that'll make my self-esteem
uh bubble up but meanwhile their status
isn't changing
and you didn't get the pop you wanted
and
you in their mind you have just more
access to [ __ ]
not like lines or ice cream lines like
just
women like movies but like shiny [ __ ]
you know you just have more access and
you have an in a seat at the table to
more shiny [ __ ] in life than that person
so there's always this added worry of
they're going to leave me they're going
to like leave me in the desert that's
why
when you see celebrity wives over
correcting or celebrity husbands like
over correcting with control
yeah like i saw i was with someone
who knew uh what's her name sophia
vergara and
her boyfriend at the time like the old
one that's like kind of weird
and in spanish he was like come on like
the way he said like come on we need to
go was
so weird and then she was like
bye and then ran away i'm like that's
someone who's
doesn't want her to slip away you know
what i mean so it's like a strong
control but that
only happens i feel like with a it
doesn't only happen with that but i feel
like it could occur more with a famous
person so what
like i think you have a different
experience of women like you
can probably set off a weird anxiety in
women then
i can't i'm very hard to read i feel
like you're really straightforward
what do you mean is what you say you
speak my language if you don't know me
that well
you think i'm um like why do you even
like me
that thing and it's like i would you
wouldn't you wouldn't have i would
change the locks
right i'm like you know you got here you
he likes you um
oh i see that probably doesn't help but
when someone's in a relationship with
you they get it
you would think but sometimes they don't
goodbye girl sometimes
bianca girl hit it you've got mail hello
lstner i'm listening to the podcast
right now
and you guys are talking about marriage
and sex and bianca says
married people have sex every single day
and said no once a week
and i think it boils down to
is do you like having sex with this
person
is sex fun is it playful is this silly
it's
whatever sex you want it to be but
do you like do you do you like this
person enough to have more sex
okay that's it that's my thoughts let me
know what you think love the podcast
it's
all brilliant i think she's right of
course she's right that's what a
relationship is do i like being
do i like being around this person no no
she's saying do i like
the type of sex we have and sometimes
women don't like the type of sex
they have but they don't say anything a
lot of women right
just they're like i gotta [ __ ] him
it's his birthday and that's not
birthday week
go ahead that's not someone who's
dying to [ __ ] you right but the and the
other issue is
this girl seems like she again not
knowing anything about her
she doesn't seem like she puts a lot in
a lot of
meaning on it sex she's like yeah it's
fun do you like you like the type of sex
you have
i can't imagine her being like
like [ __ ] staring it down like hey ah
this is [ __ ] you and me
connecting connecting you need that
connecting
sport i just want it to be fun and like
let's [ __ ] do it
same advice but that's right same vibe
as her but i think
uh a large amount of women from my
experience want it to be connected
and they want it to be for played out
and they wanted to be romantic for the
three hours before
and that's where guys go yo i
married you come on
what do you want yeah but it takes for
me to okay then it becomes like a
[ __ ] lawnmower you can't start
and you have to like massage the
lawnmower and like baby you know what
and we just want to go
a ring gang but a woman
um so yeah of course so
that's pretty cool we got some questions
from in the anchor
you're looking on anchor you can leave
us voice
questions i won't waste time
explaining what kind of listener i am
just trust that i deserve a ding
and a that's nice my question is about
online dating my friend and i both
recently turned 40 were
both divorced we have children and have
decided
as a pact to enter the world of online
dating
after dipping our toes in for a minute
so far it's [ __ ]
awful my first connection ended with him
jerking off on facetime in a bathtub
oh my gosh and hers was
that the guy was married who she thought
she had a real connection with
so my question is twofold does it get
any better
so far the odds are good but the goods
are odd in my experience
and two do we just abandon this and try
to meet somebody
organically which doesn't seem possible
in 2021
what say you i don't [ __ ] know i mean
i
me it's all here's the thing people will
not
admit about relationships it's
a lot of luck the odds of you
dating the odds of you marrying the
person you're dating even if it's
serious
i've heard i've researched whatever it's
twelve percent
and the odds of that marriage lasting is
uh half people get divorced so
it's two to one so um
six percent if you're dating somebody
seriously
the chances are six percent that you're
gonna
stay together be together forever um
you know what online dating is like it's
like it's just like being at a thrift
store
it's like you got you gotta kind of you
might go to a thrift store and you find
nothing
but a bunch of like junky community team
t-shirts you know what i liked about it
uh thrift store
socks go ahead
go ahead it's the best place to get
socks for me
so but then sometimes when you find the
greatest thing yeah and you
you keep it forever and people ask you
and it kind of smells
like piss no you gotta wash it that
nobody understands
yeah and i actually there i read an
article it's the oils you know how the
ring around the collard knowledge
oils it's oil's degrading and it starts
smelling like this
that's that smell so i anytime i buy
something from this store
i give it a bath i let them soak in a
little picture and then
like candles
[Music]
um you know what's weird about poison i
love boys men have a special place in my
heart because uh
everybody older than me played it when i
was a child but
when someone didn't grow up with it in
their life when they listened to it now
it's
it's awful almost it's it's
a very broad way it's very bad it's very
like
licking your lips candlelight that's why
i don't like r b i don't like
the genre i don't
like the genre
you don't like r b you want to hear a
funny story
no i talked about this i don't know
about a guy [ __ ] what about a girl
[ __ ]
i don't i'll j you it's probably not
about me
wow so why would i care about
[ __ ] tony braxton [ __ ] she's not
gonna [ __ ] me
no yeah i don't wanna well now i now i'm
interested
um now that i've seen your nostrils um
why would i care what kelly rowland i
just don't get what are you gonna say
about rv
um a buddy of mine this is this is
white this is some real white [ __ ] buddy
of mine
in high school he's around my age
the black kids in the school voted for
end of the road for the prom theme and
my buddy
rigged the votes so that a van morrison
song could win
he literally
and [ __ ] up and it's very fun to me i
don't think that's racist
you don't saying i don't want end of the
road i want
into the mystic by van morrison that's
just someone didn't dig
like a slow jam i
look if he's not racist i love it i will
say when things are racist
i love it for me i mean him okay
that's just someone being like disco
sucks
you know yeah great look if we're not
gonna if we're in 2021 if somebody does
something that hurts black people and
it's not racism
i'm because right there everyone a lot
of
people across all races loved voice of
men
i agree they sold 100 million records
they're
very popular and that that won't hurt
them so and they went to high school
with amir
and tariq roots motown philly
did you go near no close
i mean they were a couple years older
than me but um
motown feel it back again dude yeah
that's one of those things where like
they wouldn't talk to amir and tariq and
then
like they get less famous and tariq and
america more famous
yo it's like doug we didn't i mean i
don't know that for i know that they're
cool i'm just saying
everything is high no it really is it's
not a i'd say that showbiz isn't even
high school it's a cruise ship
where you're all on a [ __ ] cruise
ship and i see
you every so i see ben stiller every
four years and he hugs me on the lido
have you ever been and then i see
somebody else at the buffet
i see [ __ ] robert smeigle or conan no
um i just see like or i see
whomever cedric the entertainer
up on the by the pool and the gym and
we're all stuck on this [ __ ] boat
together apparently
uh in california there used to be a lot
of um
like gambling cruises like off the coast
of state yeah yeah
and apparently we're gonna vote to see
if we're going to this year there's a
vote in california to see if we're going
to allow
betting
oh like in like not just in nevada like
in california there's going to be
so that'll be fun wonka
[Laughter]
i can't tell if it's racist it's not
not racist i know but it's not racist
racial it's right it's racial that's
what that's where they do
racial i'm like the guy who i have a
corked bat and you're like
should we change the rules about bats
like i don't know but for now i can have
a quark bat
and i can say wee lee wonka um
i can't i can wear i can i can wear the
nikes that make you run
a split second faster over 10 seconds
there's a nike new nike running shoe
that
is like should be illegal but they can't
quite
figure out women should just have it at
night you're welcome
you're still going to get popped sorry
ladies still not fast enough
um ejaculation goodbye sorry for the
written
q tried recording and it sounds awful a
long time listener
normally wednesday thursday whenever i
see it on youtube
i've always felt a lot of pressure as a
man to perform sexually i've never had
any issues with boners except once when
i was getting
over an x and wasn't really ready i'm
giving love oral
down with massages i have a whole theory
about massages
i don't like making people give me
massages it's weird wait
for money or friends like i'll go to a
thing
a girl that's weird it's like yeah and
then when you're done mow my lawn
it's like i hire someone to do this
right um
and they're never as good they're not
good and then they do this
at the end no they do the compound
okay we're done and you're like that's
it and as a guy we're constantly trying
to feel the side of your boob
so you you can't trust us either all
right i'm i'm giving love oil down with
massages vocal
try to give my partner off before i get
mine and i advocate for myself but i'm
not too progressive my questions are
a what is a woman's obligation to
perform
sexually be if a sexual thing doesn't go
great
how can i shift the shame and icky
feelings or that away from myself and
under the situation
c how to better identify traits in
people to avoid or be aware of
so that casually casual things feel less
disorienting empty
slash love bombing this guy introduced
love bombing
i match with a young lady on on a dating
app and i thought she was gorgeous she
liked
arts and books and i liked and
that i like and i found her physically
sexy and she was mentioning that she
wasn't looking for anything serious
and she found me cute all good we go on
a date it's really going well
but i've gotta run home to walk my dog i
didn't invite her over we schedule next
time for a movie night at my place
we're chatting all week and having
somewhat deep conversations and i'm
feeling like we're connecting she comes
over
i ordered dinner she brought over a
massive amount of drinks and snacks and
we eat and drink and listen to music
we watch some john mullaney wouldn't
have been my first choice
uh get to making out then we go to my
bedroom
okay dang everything just sort of this
is a long walk
uh and everything just sort of slows
down we make out some more we get naked
this person
who'd uh been game for whatever who
brought over probably 120 in snacks
he's been indulging my dumb quests all
week i've been sharing book wrecks
and what and what not just sort of laid
there it went down on her for quite a
while and her body felt like
uh felt into it but she didn't come we
tried fingering
uh still didn't make it tried sex i hate
condom sex but i'm trying
she's asking me to go much much slower
uh than i'd like and i'm out of rhythm
and after a bit of fumbling around it's
just sort of over i didn't come she
didn't either and she did
she leaves at about 1 or 2 a.m which was
her plan the whole time
she didn't offer her head or take an
issue all right this is he should have
just
he already asked the questions but it's
fun to hear about people what is the
next morning
doing events anymore something didn't
feel right she says
blah blah blah right so but what are you
saying what's a woman's responsibility
sexually um like what does
what does a lady me and a friend always
talk about this
like when a woman's like she's good and
bad you're like
so you propped yourself up in different
ways
right did you lay there well did you
did you hold the all fours position well
like we
it's we're going to the gym you're the
you're the mat
basically you're the yoga mat we're
doing yoga
now what does a woman know
uh you're welcome ladies i'm single
out in venice wonder go ahead
um yeah uh also can i just read this
part which is really funny he says
she just disappeared i waited for a few
days sent info blah blah blah blah blah
delete her number let it go
i'm a little bummed because it felt like
blah blah blah
i think i projected a lot onto this
person because they claimed to like
tony morris what binks thinks i'm like
this guy
can't it sounds like a kind of a dream
for ladies honestly like
tony morrison like i love that it's just
very funny it's like the ends runs
parallel to what tony morrison described
as
literary archaeology i one with his
actual
question like he's it's a two-parter
just sometimes
if it feels awkward the the
magic sparkles like kind of go away with
the awkwardness
like i well i don't want to call her out
but you had a funny kissing situation
where you're
like can't come back from that no this
is not going to work i don't remember
what it was
oh yeah i can tell you but whatever
another time not another time yeah uh
but yeah anyway so
i do think that
uh i don't i think okay so if
something's awkward
but if we're trying and it's awkward and
you're the one who's
offering ideas and i'm accepting them
but it's still not very awkward it's
still not getting better
i don't know i don't know i don't
i'm not one of well here's the question
do you believe in like
we can get better i'm always like nah
i've never
improved more than 40 percent that's a
lot that's huge but they had happened
like twice
okay it's pretty good yeah but the rest
of the time it's like
either you're already at 90 and you can
make it 10
better through choking and those sort of
you know through apparatus and toys
outdoors
this is why i do believe in it because
people are have trauma and are awkward
as [ __ ] sometimes at first
and the moment they feel a little
comfortable
it can get better i've experienced it
get better
not super i don't it depends on the
person
if i'm willing to try to make it do you
think that it's
so it's been you believe guys have
trauma and
everybody has trump we all know women
have trauma but i'm saying do guys have
trauma
that that um
and that affects their sex life and then
the next time
you talk about it and it's better um i
don't know that
black and white but i think i've
experienced that because like you said
you guys are doing
a lot of it a lot of it's on you and
sometimes that pressure can mentally
connect to the you know the penis
and sometimes it's like oh okay yeah
that's like stage frighty
kind of sure like uh bombing
you're like no i'm actually not this bad
yeah so
that stuff i feel like if you can get
mentally over that you're fine
but i feel like that stuff probably
happens because if you don't know
somebody and i'm just like
you know that weird like the tides turn
in you where you're like i don't like
this
but i don't know you enough to be like
no no no don't look very [ __ ] like that
you're
fire poking it like you have to just be
cool with a little bit of
this isn't good right and
i also think women should be more direct
and that's the nice part about
oral as women will guess what go the
amount of times i've been direct and
it's gone
terrible yeah where it's like hurt
feelings
emotional explosion of like whatever you
know what maybe little it's just like
yeah man i'm
like if i was raking your dick with my
teeth i'm listening
i'm brocard rocker
uh you would tell someone to stop
yep the guys aren't always
and girls i feel like girls in bed are
pretty cool like
they're kind of down with what you're
down with you know
what do you think is that true uh no i
mean yes and no
sometimes yeah no sometimes yes
sometimes no you don't think i feel like
they're pretty
accommodating a comedy i mean i don't i
look
people like what they like right that's
fine but i don't even talk about that
i mean i'm not talking about i mean now
i'm not talking about like the
end i'm talking about during they're
rule oriented how
here's people like what they like like
you
a woman will be like yeah do it but they
whatever that thing is
i don't think they want to do it for
more than 30 seconds you know what i
mean
it's not like infinite you have infinite
time to do this
this thing i don't like is there an
amount of
foreplay that's too much for a woman can
foreplay take too long
i'm not saying obviously guy if a guy's
not making you
finish and then let's wrap it up
babe but i'm saying i'm kind of of the
mind now that
if whereas guys at the be from like
kissing to
[ __ ] guys could be like three and a
half minutes
yeah that's really good for us right
whereas if you told a woman
it's gonna be 40 minutes she'd be like
okay
40 minutes of all of us are four of
later
back and forth forward play and and then
we'll start
intercourse in 40 minutes i think women
would be like
all right guys like
three minutes is about right for me we
just have our sexual organs function
differently
i know we need a huge issue it's a huge
issue goodbye i've been married
for only six months and to bianca's
point all we do is [ __ ]
but all we did before we got married was
[ __ ] so not much has changed we are in
the
four days a week club that's and that's
she's saying all we do is [ __ ]
yeah so and that's four days a week but
that's only because my wife's son from a
pre
previous relationship is with us the
other three days and we live in close
quarters
otherwise it would be a certified freak
seven days a week my wife didn't have
sex very often in a previous
relationship
but can't get enough at ours is it
possible there are other factors that
may cause causal
couples from [ __ ] regularly i.e men
being bad at bringing women to climax
stigmas about going down on women
and or a lack of open honest
communication i think we need to just to
normalize discussing our sex life
the only way things get better is when
you talk about them
what thing what thing you're thinking
what we just said yeah
yeah yep would you
something you that would hurt your
feelings
if someone's just being honest like hey
i don't love when you oh no i wouldn't
you're not i
no i wouldn't care at all okay i
wouldn't care at all
this is interesting a woman one time got
mad at me
because i was like hey are you having
orgasms
and she was like yeah i was like okay
because i can't tell and she's like you
couldn't tell she doesn't make a noise
not she didn't make much of a noise and
she was
kind of a little mad at me for
saying it and i know that women don't
want to get like guys are counting
yeah but my point was like i can't have
an orgasm until you do
so if i don't know if you've had one i
don't know what to do
i don't i got to make plans what did she
say after that
she's like okay i'll just say like i
came
yeah but i don't think i if i remember
correctly we didn't hang out again
so she i do believe she did she was
i thought she was but it was just so
vague
um and once i asked for clarification it
was like
the mystery was gone yeah like okay i'm
sorry ma'am
i just needed something i needed to know
something you'll need a red light
i don't know when he's on deck eta
dog yeah instead of just like no go wait
out front
i'd prefer to know an eta
that's all i'm saying yeah so i think
you're on her side if i had to
and i don't believe i think you don't
believe that she was having orgasms i
don't think you believe in me
i do good email
you have touched on this very lightly we
did touch lightly
uh but i'm curious about a deeper dive i
found myself
doing deeper and deeper dives
basically how do you feel about potly
relationships
even open poly ones the
oversimplification is that i've
uh ha is that i have six bonded partners
so many descriptive as girlfriends for
the uninitiated
uh who i who i have slept with
and we do all the quote regular
relationship things like travel
birthdays parties deep conversations etc
etc usually in two or three person
configurations we all get along
oh yeah the only open poly portion
the only open poly portion fuels
things like not mixing finances or
cohabitating but we are bonded and love
each other nonetheless
this also may be the reason the long
distance thing with one of my partners
works
everything is up and up everything is on
the up and up i basically
live the life of a dude who cheats on
multiple partners but without any of the
cheating
thoughts is it oh he's the one man and
it's all girls
or do they get to have that's my take
ah that's just that's a little sister
wavy
i'm with it i guess seven you were not
worth it
are you kidding me neil you're willing i
love you about it
you know i love group outings you know i
love picking up multiple women
if five women are mad at it i love
saying hey is your seat belt on back
there
to a woman i'm gonna be raw dogging with
three other women later
i love the full
portfolio of experience dating
experiences
i don't i if if five women was mad were
mad at you at the same time
you would explode well i'd just leave
started i'd start a new sex farm
you'd you're like i'm gonna go to i mean
you would right
here but but you know because it's women
you know what would happen
okay one of the women would play the
other woman
the other woman's anger at me against
her
and use it as a way to get it yes you
can be living in a bachelor this is a
nightmare right but you know who's
having a great time on the bachelor
is the bachelor yeah it's the women that
are in trouble
the bachelor has also bad times a bunch
of no one loves when women are mad at
them especially men
no especially yeah uh
is the is the sex worth like i don't
know what's worse
six women that you're having sex with
mad at you or one woman that you're
having sex
with maddie it's all it's just a mixed
bag
it's what's your bandwidth now everybody
knows i'm too sensitive
if you listen to this episode from the
beginning a lot of people come in the
middle
a lot of people commit fast forward to
the middle because they're weird uh
you best of luck bro i don't know what
to do it sounds it sounds like magical
horror
um hey neil and bianca neil just wanted
to make a couple points regarding your
stance on obese people and not because i
think it's relevant but i feel right in
assuming you would feel this
correspondence would be incomplete
without the disclosure that i would
be considered and classified as obese by
any measure it was a run-on sentence uh
wouldn't be surprised he he uh he
he identifies the run on her nanny
i just don't know the uh it wouldn't
surprise me if i were morbidly obese
hold for applause
uh i just don't know the medical
definition of it i think
he i read this okay because
he's saying that that uh blaming
fat people for being fat is like
is is like casual racism that it's
like i'm accepting it's acceptable
bigotry
because i'm saying they did it to
themselves
um i am of the mind
as a comedian
i remember larry miller the great
legendary comedian
said to dave one time in the 90s that
there
are no such thing as bad audiences and
it's a thing i've talked to seinfeld
about
it doesn't it doesn't help make me a
better comedian to think that
the audience is bad i didn't say when i
bombed last night the audiences were bad
i was off so so i will improve myself
another friend of mine will call her cat
said that i she's like i notice that you
blame the victim in a lot of situations
people often automatically eating sexual
assault that's no no
no no no no meaning you're responsible
for for your behavior and
outcomes or you're you're largely
responsible for a lot of the
stuff that or some of the stuff that
happens in your life i believe that it
will serve your
it will serve you well to believe that
uh you don't work hard enough or you
need to focus more or
you need to improve some way like me
last night
i need to figure out a way to regulate
my emotions so
with overweight people i understand that
there are
a lot of forces laid against you i
understand that there are cultural
forces
i understand that there are genetic
forces and what i'm
my take is i am sympathetic to them
and i believe that you have
more agency in this than you
may think you do that's
the that's the entirety of my take on
obese people and i believe it's gotten
better than
it's your fault over the time thank you
ayahuasca
i have evolved what a podcast to watch
growth like this
he also said still a big fan and i have
no doubt if you read this you'll take
apart my argument faster than a
than the whole baguette i ate yesterday
uh no you didn't you just you respect uh
yeah like i don't
you know i get having bad habits
i have bad habits and which is why i
wear a shock bracelet
like i'm not not doing this no no i'm
not walk
[Music]
hey neil and binks your resident
jamaican here just to clear the air
bumbaclot along with blood clot refer to
sanitary
napkins bamba in this case is generally
accepted as vagina
or just the nether region of a woman in
general
we have another term that is gender
bureau
crotches you wash your crotches okay
the reason for the cloth versus clot
argument is because
like most countries with black people
our general lexicon changes
the th sound with a t like a hard t
or a d double t double d etc
jamaican specifically has other oddities
like pronouncing silent
h's or making audible ones silent like
h is pronounced and
hamper is pronounced emperor
i don't know uh i'm an american-born
jamaican
uh so these things i've learned well
while a
ute oh youth yout wala huge
hope this broadens horizons
i'm not sure it did it was confusing
um the thing about
black people making th's
it's like i've never met by a person no
i got to take a bat
right but i got to take a bath i got to
take me
back jamaican but i don't know
um no i don't know what he exactly
like in panama they speak with a patois
because
of the west indies immigrants but
yeah i don't know i think he's talking
about patois accents
here i would like to declare moratorium
on australia letters and
and bubba clot letters i think we've got
oh there's a lot more
going guys it's over
shut it down no more obama cloud we
figured it out
we should there's no more australians no
more dms about it
there's ten more things that are on the
list that we get too many letters about
that
talk about too much fat we could also
i've
you guys needed polyamory we talked
about it [ __ ] every third week
you guys need to do a deep dive i we're
wearing [ __ ] scuba suits buddy
goodbye
you've got mail hey guys nothing clever
here first time email or was just
listening to another gem of an episode
and notice how an email
they often do compliments this is a
great question
as they often do compliments neil on his
thoughts on a topic you guys covered
and then compliment bianca on her beauty
yep
nothing wrong with that i mean she is
beautiful but the question to bianca is
given that you both give your input the
same as neil
that you give your input the same as
neil does in this podcast does it ever
bother you that the feelers tend to
recognize your beauty more than they do
your brains
or is it recognizing recognition of
either
uh just as valuable to you there's a
larger question here for women in
general about whether a compliment about
their looks is generally
always good enough for them good enough
to them
uh regardless of what else they're
contributing at the moment
or if there's a point where recognition
of a parent is no longer enough to feed
the ego
or other sensibility genuinely curious
as a man just trying to understand
uh more about how different or similar
men and women really are under the hood
um yeah
there's a few things going on so one is
that this is called how neal feel you're
a famous comedian people
like your brand of comedy they also like
you from
either sketchy sketches it's a pretty
impressive body of work
it is so uh the same like when you see
comics like you know i've seen martin
come in and not do that well but
everyone's dying
laughing because it's like i know that
guy right so when
people come here i think people come
here a lot for you
and you're they already trust that you
vetted your opinion enough that they can
kind of
either you know sometimes adopt it
in their own circle so i think you
you'll your take on things holds
more weight if you're mad at me for
something we'll get way more mailed than
if i'm at you even if it's like a
similar point
there's times where i'll make a like a
rift or a tag or something and then
if you repeat it it's very it's like you
know or there's times where you talk
you say oh you said a funny thing last
episode i didn't give you credit for it
you know what i mean so i think
that i think you're the
co-host of a podcast if someone's more
famous
it the the
you know the culture around them is what
you make like if you objectified me more
i think i'd get way more dick pics
you know i think if i was on rogan more
and i mean
and i think i'd be i think i'd have
really gross comments most people
actually
are really respectful when they reach
out to me because you also respect me
right as a man and sadly enough like
men take cues from men so if you talk to
me i was a [ __ ] idiot
and you objectified me all the time i
would get that too
from the same people people do cut you
off in conversation on the street though
yeah
uh so i understand i
fully understand what this is i
understand
my role in it i've worked with a lot of
comedians in
uh like just acting wise you you
gotta i don't know i'm not saying i have
to play a role but there is a
tea up i do when you're going on
something i'm not you know you're you
just have to kind of play a role and
that does reflect in
it it goes on to the audience and it and
it bounces back to us so i see it it
doesn't
bother me because you know when you see
something functioning
it's like yeah okay that makes sense i
get it it is it does
what the [ __ ] you know what he didn't
say does it hurt my feelings that no one
ever says i'm hot
it's not about you now but you know what
i mean all about you no but do you know
what i mean like no one ever
it that i noticed that a friend of mine
whenever one of his daughters
implemented who looks like that though i
agree
but yeah okay i agree no no of course um
friend of mine always
i'll be on the phone with him and he'll
go like
his daughter will walk in he'll be like
what is beautiful and i'm like
you know dude raising him you know with
that beauty
and his point is like
he's of the mind that women would always
if women
and it's it's just his opinion if women
were given the choice
of you can be called smart or beautiful
that and to which women may say why not
both
not not possible but of course that's
where the female brain goes
if they had to pick one they would pick
beautiful and i don't
i can't entirely disagree this is the
thing with me
just my life style is that when i was
like in my adolescent hood i was very
insecure
about my looks and so i kind of unlike
most women
okay but i also dress myself down and i
also like a big mouth
i like making jokes so there was a
different part of my personality that i
wanted to shine more like i almost grew
up similar to a comedian where
like i'll ha don't talk about my
physical appearance i will be the class
clown i'll be the one like
making jokes and stuff like that that's
how i grew up and it was almost like
i'm gonna reject myself out of this
before i can get rejected so
i remember i like straightened my hair
once and then
everyone wanted to [ __ ] me mm-hmm and i
always wore it back with like 5 000
clips in there and then one day i was
like i'm just going to get it like i'm
just going to come to school with it
straight
and i wore like a tighter shirt
and then everyone was really like really
short shorts
no i didn't do it like that but i just
dressed up jeans and t-shirts clear
heels
what the [ __ ] and that day everything it
was a weird
no no neil it was a it was the moment i
realized that everyone is full of [ __ ]
because i was like no one said hi to me
before like i had my friends
but these [ __ ] were not talking
to me this girl was not talking to me
these popular people weren't talking to
me and then i look i
straightened my hair and put on a cute
like tight
guess shirt yeah now everyone is like
you look and that's
like i so i don't put i almost don't
believe when people like
hey beautiful it's like today right now
sure
by the way they've started treating me
nicer at that restaurant i go to
because i think they watch the mark
twain thing who what restaurant they're
right
i just there's another there's like a
level of respect that i was not getting
before
do you believe it i just don't believe i
like it it's not incredibly
disappointing
and incredibly obvious about their
behavior and think you're not going to
notice
so it depends are you someone that it's
like i see what you're doing
but it feels damn good are you like i
see what you're doing and
you're doing this for you to an
anonymous friend's point
which what compliment
if put a gun to your head not even you
most women
you and most women which compliment do
you think they prefer
me i don't want the beautiful because i
don't always i just don't believe it
like when people tell me like yours i'm
like
but what do you think they mean uh no i
just think
that we compliment people more for us
you know what i mean because i don't
know what do you i mean if someone's
just like oh you look great today or
something like that that's fine
but also there is a weird thing as a
woman it's like
beautiful beauty beautiful beautiful
like
for our whole lives it does lose a
little bit of weight after a while
you know yeah i guess it's like but if
you stop hearing it then you're like
what happened to that
no okay but that's just me i think he
may be in the minority but i don't know
yeah but it also i think is to the point
how i grew up when it was just so easy
to get because
something dumb i did to my hair and then
when if i put my hair back no one would
compliment me something beautiful
it just loot you just look disillusioned
they almost compliment effort
honestly like you look effortful
[Music]
let's wrap it up um
coverage question to you would you
rather be told you're funny or you're
good-looking
similarly i know
i'm funny so it's like where if a girl
likes me on social media and doesn't
know i'm a comedian
i'm like jesus christ and he's like
[ __ ]
i got it man because if you see that
that's like the normal that's the thing
that gets them in the shop
right and uh so if if you just think i'm
good looking then [ __ ]
right this way here's my netflix
password
ejaculation
[Music]
there was a mistake earlier where we
thought we had to take the [ __ ] and
there's been a correction
where we don't so thank you
[Music]
[Music]